you've heard rumors about it you may
have even read some articles about it
it's finally here though Apple's gotta
watch this is the Apple watch actually
there are going to be more than one
Apple watches there's going to be a
three different families a low range of
mid range and an upper end the watch
works with your iPhone it is backwards
compatible all the way to the iphone 5
it will not be available until 2015 at
which point prices will start at three
hundred and forty nine dollars Apple has
created different bands and different
materials there's anodized aluminum
stainless steel as you see here and gold
the bands come in rubber in leather in
steel in other materials as well they
have a new controller here which is
called the digital crown which allows
you to access different features on the
watch as well as a touch screen that
will allow you to swipe through
different applications and different
functions if Apple's newest product
since the iPad which was nearly four
years ago it incorporates a very subtle
haptic feedback on the back of the watch
that taps your wrist to alert you when
somebody has sent you a text or an email
it also has a suite of fitness features
including pulse detection as well as
accelerometer and other features so that
this will not only help keep the time
and keep you informed but Apple is
saying keep you healthier